handshakes
why are they so awkward I hate
handshakes today we're gonna look at
some of the most Awkward handshakes just
for the pure cringe of it and we'll
examine some of mine just to see where
it went wrong hopefully I feel less bad
about myself
we all had a bad handshake at some point
in our life okay the problem with me is
I'll never forget I remember every
single detail I'll wake up in the middle
of the night with cold sweat and me like
why did I up that handshake
let's look at some immortalized
handshakes wait there's no way Obama has
an awkward handshake he's such a cool
guy
there it is too bad are you serious
painfully awkward oh you happening you
haven't even seen pain ABC News you
don't know my suffering you don't even
know my stuff right look at that look at
that guy's dead dead look he's like
we that up then we that's awkward
this is my favorite one I think because
let's just this is watch it's beautiful
they do the shake Oh
[Music]
why how listen you gotta let go you
gotta know when to let go some people
don't know when to let go the guy's like
alright well I guess we're going on a
little journey now there's another one
like that we've all been in that one
handshake where that guy or a girl just
holds on for too long please let go how
are they still only know I can't last
longer I can't I can't watch this
it hurts
her cuz he's got to review this
car and he's like you know
I'm not letting go of your hand until
you give me a good review for the camera
your
please please let go of the hand
let go of the hand let go there yeah
alright I think I've got gathered enough
courage to watch one one of my awkward
handshakes this one happened literally
like a week ago Jack let me just let
this just be clear that was Jack that
up okay that was that was hell
okay let's see what happened let's
deconstruct he went for the handshake I
he went for the handshake and then he
went away how am I supposed how do you
go away if you go just commit commit
Jack have you heard of commitment I bet
you haven't cuz you're what something
bad that's that's 100% on Jack that's
one of Jack and that's final nothing
else can I just say can I just say and
to myself for that matter if you if you
were ever ever you ever find yourself on
a gaming show whatsoever whatever
happens do not shake their hand
do not shake any hints no no bro fists
no high fives
no nothing because this is what happened
I've seen it before I don't know why why
does this bother me so much nothing
bothers me Trump Trump became president
I don't care and an awkward handshake
that's the worst
now the thing that you see that guy he
has an earpiece he has to talk to other
people he's not gonna see your hand
just don't shake his head
[Music]
once and shake can ruin everything
oh that's gonna be gay that was look at
that guy's face that's the face you make
when you want to die
that guy it up that guy's
literally jacksepticeye the guy on the
left
well thanks a lot Chris I appreciate
three hands over the mic lock rooms I
appreciate you coming out here is a
pleasure hey really nice to meet you uh
sure sure sure buddy
I think this is probably my my favorite
one I could say I'm a kind of a
connoisseur of awkward handshake but I I
think this one has to be my favorite
ryan secrets high fives blind guy no you
won't see anyone in California Ryan
Seacrest
did he ever comment about that I think
that's what makes it even better the
fact that he never acknowledged it like
oh my god I tried a high five a blind
guy I think I think I gathered enough
courage to watch another one of mine you
see my reaction right away why is it so
hard to me am i that awkward I don't
think I'm that awkward I just can't do
handshake don't handshake I don't want
you I don't want to touch you okay he'll
faint yes who grabs why would you grab
Ethan what's wrong with you that was a
high five those cleared a high five all
right
and the Conan one wish you all keep
sending to me by the way so Kate would
you please stop doing that
who handshakes during a gaming session
you high-five
you go like this branching but just not
my problem well I don't ever
want to do that and the guy ain't
it up down look at him he did it wrong
as well it's not just me I'm not the
only one look at that that's equally bad
okay can you stop can you stop what else
do we got oh this video so he's
challenging these girls paid actresses I
should probably call them to make an
awkward handshake with them and if they
fail they have to make out with him the
ultimate punishment
I didn't even realize I made that fade
Jesus
hey Chris why don't you why don't you
get a suit that fits you why don't you
get a properly tailored suit instead of
paying for all these women to kiss you
all right I mean it doesn't seem like a
bad job they're all attractive women
nice know what see but come on girls you
can do better you don't have to kiss
Chris Monroe because you up a
handshake because I will if I kiss
everyone I up a handshake with I
would probably have herpes
six times over 20 times a million times
you up a handshake you pay the
consequences you don't just make out
with people all right it it kind of
triggers me because I have this
condition and he's clearly making fun of
it and I don't think that's fair I don't
think that's a right fair at all mr.
Critz Monroe what the are you guys
treating me this way what just happened
hey Hitler Oh historically awkward
handshake what did Hitler then Hitler
didn't they just have an awkward
handshake Oh finally I can relate to
someone I'm kidding I'm kidding
that's a prick he did it pretty smooth
you know the sweet man Hitler he he
didn't just do that okay sorry too far
all right this one I thought was fake it
just seemed too dumb to not be real so
it's this guy with no arms and he shoots
too
he shoots some wins gold he actually
absolutely incredible feat like feet at
it I mean feet feet nut ah Sh oh no look
at that
you idiot
I thought that was fake to be fair like
what what do you do with with do you bow
you got a bow bow bow that's it we need
to bring back the bowing simple like
Japan why is it so hard can we just have
one universal thing I don't care what it
is I just want one thing so it doesn't
have to be so awkward the most awkward
handshake I don't know why it's funny I
think I think it's because people are
put in a spot where they don't know how
to act
we're so program oh this is getting deep
we're so programmed in our society not
just in what we say or how we act or how
what we eat but when we're put in a
situation then where we don't know what
to do it's just hilarious I realized
what I must do now I must take this to
the great outdoors and I must greet some
strangers and practice I will become the
handshake master
all right brush that was just video I
hope you enjoyed watching now I wanted
to be clear that if you see me do not
interact with me whatsoever you may you
may bow alright here's the thing if you
ever see me I want you to bow bow to
your sensei pretty much and that's
pretty much all you're allowed to do at
this point okay
don't that's it no offense just don't
touch I'm kidding I'm joking
just don't I know I know I just know you
guys and I know you're gonna with
me just because I gave you this very
personal information all right but
anyway if you enjoyed this video I think
you might enjoy this one oh it's another
one about handshakes how about that
running out of ideas peds